ضم الينا مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر
اسماعيل قربنا مما تشهده اليوم خان يونس
وهي المنطقه الاكثر سخونه في هذه المرحله
من
المعارك نعم الاكثر سخونه بالفعل خاصه مع
استمرار عملي القصف واستهداف تجمعات
لمواطنين في اكثر من منطقه من محافظه
خانيونس كان الاستهداف الابرز في منطقه
مدينه حمد حيث استهدفت طائرات الاحتلال
مجموعه من المواطنين ادى ذلك الى ارتقاء
اربعه شهداء اضافه الى استهداف اخر في
منطقه السطر الغربي في محافظه خانيونس ادى
ذلك الى ارتقاء احد الشهداء اضافه الى
عمليات اطلاق نار من قبل اليات الاحتلال
باتجاه مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ادى ذلك الارتقاء احد
طواقم الهلال الاحمر داخل المستشفى في ظل
استمرار عمليات القصف ايضا المدفعي الى
جانب ما يتم من عمليات اطلاق نار من قبل
اليات الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه كان هناك
قبل قليل استهداف جديد في منطقه بني سهيله
تحديدا لتجمع المواطنين ايضا بالقرب من
احدى المدارس وهذه المنطقه مخلاه تماما
بسبب بسبب العمليه العسكريه البريه التي
نفذت قبل تقريبا اكثر من 55 يوما وتستمر
حتى هذه اللحظه في المناطق الشرقيه
للمحافظه ادى هذا القصف الاخير الى اصابه
اثنين من المواطنين تم نقل هذه الاصابات
الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي نتحدث بان في
الساعه الاخيره هناك اكثر من عمليه قصف
تمت لتجمعات مواطنين ادت الى ارتقاء اكثر
من سته شهداء حتى هذه اللحظه في حين ان
القصف المدفعي مستمر في الاجزاء الغربيه
لمحافظه خانيونس تحديدا في منطقه المعسكر
وفي محيط مستشفى ناصر الذي يتعرض لحصار
مطبق من قبل اليات الاحتلال وهذا الحصار
مفروض منذ اكثر من تسعه ايام على المستشفى
وكذلك مستشفى حي الامل في منطقه غرب
خانيونس في ظل هذا القصف المدفعي العنيف
الذي يتم من قبل اليات الاحتلال هناك ايضا
غارات جويه تنفذها طائرات الاحتلال في
اكثر من منطقه وتركزت عمليات القصف في وسط
محافظه خانيونس في منطقه البلد والى الشرق
من معسكر خانيونس ايضا وهناك عمليات نسف
تتم بين الحين والاخر يقوم بها جنود
الاحتلال في اكثر من منطقه تحديدا في وسط
المحافظه وعمليات القصف المدفعي تتجدد بين
الحين والاخر في مناطق متعدده من المناطق
الشرقيه سواء في منطقه القراره وكذلك في
منطقه بني سهيله وكذلك في حي المناره
القريب منا هنا حيث تعرضت هذه المنطقه
لقصف عنيف منذ صباح هذا اليوم ويستمر حتى
هذه اللحظات اصوات انفجارات كبيره وشديده
نتيجه عمليات القصف المدفعي الت تنفذها
الي الاحتلال هناك عمليات انتشال لشهداء
ايضا بين الحين والاخر من مناطق مختلفه من
المحافظه خاصه من الاجزاء الشرقيه
المواطنون يتحركون باتجاه المناطق التي
انسحبت منها اليات الاحتلال مؤخرا وينجحون
في كثير من الاحيان بنقل اعداد من الشهداء
عبر عربات باتجاه مستشفيات المحافظه خاصه
مستشفى غزه الاوروبي في خانيونس وايضا
نتحدث بان هناك نقاط طبيه تتلقى و تستقبل
بين الحين والاخر اصابات في صفوف
المواطنين جراء اطلاق النار من قبل اليات
الاحتلال وكذلك القصف المدفعي الكثيف
والعنيف في مناطق غرب محافظه خانيونس
الاوضاع الانسانيه ايضا ماساويه جدا داخل
مجمع ناصر الطبي في ظل يعني تراجع عمليات
امدادات الوقود وكذلك امدادات الغذاء له
هذا المستشفى الذي يضم اكثر من 300 مريض
اضافه الى اكثر من 3000 نازح داخل هذا
المستشفى وتزداد اعداد النازحين داخل
مستشفى في ظل نزوح المواطنين من المناطق
القريبه من هذا المستشفى باتجاه باتجاه
هذا المستشفى نظرا لعمليات القصف العنيف
التي تتم من قبل الي الاحتلال لمنازل
المواطنين في محيط هذا المستشفى شكرا
جزيلا لك اسماعيل